This question has been coming to me from many children
that how can I remember such difficult words?
So do a little exercise.
Not many people know this trick,
but let me definitely share with you the
things that I can tell you.  I am making a list and
then pause the video and speak to
see if you have remembered the names of all these things.
You must have missed some things. Observe this image
here for a
second. We call it
visual memory, so whenever you  Read it actively and
try to visualize it, then the thing
returns in a better way.
Now we will read it with amazing tips.
Join further on Bol Brahmastra,
your favorite channel of Don't Wari.